ce que nous avons créé ici est peut-être unique dans
toute l'existence humaine tout au long de la façon dont nous avons
créé le paradis, nous faisons comment vous êtes
si incroyables les enfants sont incroyables le
mien doit être à l'hôpital en ce
moment est-elle partie
voyons la tête de la maladie que nous pouvons '  t aller aux
funérailles de maman faisons ce qu'on nous dit
nous voulons te voir maman grand-mère ne peut pas
nous impressionner
maintenant c'est ton premier vrai test
souviens-toi de ton entraînement ils ont des hot-
dogs
qu'est-ce que l'eau empoisonnée au cola
si heureux que notre famille soit ensemble
local et bio comment avez-vous tué ces
poulets
écoutez agir très bien au revoir merci votre
poulet d'histoire des arts alors vous l'achetez je
suis déjà mort
le camion d'actes de baiser dont ils ont besoin pour aller dans
une vraie école j'espère sincèrement que vous êtes en
demande je pense  tu as fait ta
fille m'a appris beaucoup de choses tout à l'
heure seras-tu ma femme à
moins que cela ne sorte d'un livre je ne
sais rien non plus
même s'ils survivent à tout ce que
tu leur fais  va être
totalement pris au dépourvu pour le vrai w  orld
et il se trouve que je pense que le contraire est
vrai c'est un enfant de toi si je voulais
te frapper je t'aurais frappé
Abbey et j'ai décidé de travailler dans un
dossier pour la garde des enfants
vont-ils nous emmener avec toi c'est
possible notre  Les enfants seront
philosophe Keeler's me rend triste et
décris ce que nous t'avons